it's time to babble the [ __ ] on
[Music]
yes Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I guess I could have [ __ ] stayed at
home
oh stop if they love you this is
Wednesday night in London ladies and
gentlemen
so let's babble the [ __ ] on I'm Kevin
Smith I'm Ralph Garman
[Applause]
welcome ladies and gentlemen oh my god
it's been a fantastic week abroad with
[ __ ] Babel and Ralph's and Ralph's
giant balls yes thank you so much for
being here this evening thanks to all of
the UK at Manchester and Birmingham and
then Edinburgh and Dublin all the places
we visited this past week have just been
so incredibly welcoming and warm and
friendly and just it's been a great
great trip and I wanted to say really
quickly before we go any further I am so
lucky to be able to come across the
ocean and meet so many great people who
appreciate what I do but none of it
would be possible without the gentleman
to my right mr. Kevin Smith who makes it
all possible so thank you so much for
making this happen it's been a blast sir
so thanks for sharing your audience with
me for all these years
vice versa man's all different audience
and stuff we do this together stop it
you're gonna make me cry on stage holy
[ __ ] man I let me [ __ ] tell you this
[ __ ] story so we got here to London
just today we flew in and then who knew
was closed
that was what surprised me what do you
mean the centre of London was closed
yeah there's a lot of non-movement going
yes I just thought that was [ __ ]
normal for London like the traffic
you just can't [ __ ] move and [ __ ] is
so weird being in a car I'm watching
pedestrians lap you you know so we got
to the hotel in London and checked in
and [ __ ] and the centred myself with
some fine local smoke and then was
looking for some hummus because
instantly I was like need hummus the
vegan go to when you're abroad and stuff
and legendary garbanzo yes yeah grind
that [ __ ] to grind that chickpea up I
don't want to eat it as a chickpea but
if you chew it up like a bird and spit
it in my mouth I'll eat it Oh
see if they pay extra for that in value
well that's vegan so yeah yes so I asked
the folks at the front desk guys I came
in where's the nearest place I'd get
some hummus and falafel and they were
like oh it's like literally a four
minute walk from here oh my god [ __ ]
I'm so baked I'll totally walk and it
was so great man I felt like it was like
cuz it was just a lovely walk the day
has been beautiful for those following
along at home you know the assuming the
weather is like London it wasn't it was
better than Los Angeles been raining in
Los Angeles all week we've had this
glorious weather while we've been over
here and today was absolutely no
difference so I'm [ __ ] walking along
the streets men singing like I'm in
Sweeney Todd and she had just admitted
the [ __ ] out of myself and then find
this place they sent me to the the it
was a Lebanese restaurant and so I was
like hey man I'm looking for some hummus
they like you come to the right place
sit sit eat and I'm like [ __ ] hey so
I ordered told us our mob played falafel
and some [ __ ] hummus and some pitas
and stuff and I had like those earbuds
in and I was watching an episode of
flash the season finale am I gonna spoil
it the season finale of flash aired in
the state so I was able to watch it over
here unlike my iTunes and [ __ ] and it
and without spoiling it it is [ __ ]
crazy emotional no like I so I was
bawling by the end of the [ __ ] show
not even just like rolling a tear like
well done but just like oh I show gets
me every time so the dude who was
serving me like came over cuz Mikey you
know I'd been done my shows were just
kind of sitting there and I was trying
to keep the tears in the corner and [ __ ]
like that but I couldn't avoid him when
he came over so he goes are you okay is
it the food and I said no no he goes
this is [ __ ] killed me goes are you
sad that you're an American
[Applause]
yes but I was like inherently I believe
you're right oh it's [ __ ] dope man so
but I was hours already [ __ ]
emotional today don't make me motor so
[ __ ] sweet well that was like last
season finale sweet I don't know about
that it was a run Kevin run or anything
like this
oh it's [ __ ] dope wow you the o2 for
god sakes how cool is this place this is
fantastic i I've been here before it's
so [ __ ] strange like when when I knew
we were coming here this is where we
were wrapping up I was like oh wait I've
[ __ ] been there and then when I came
it through the back door I bet you did
Big Boy because that's how I like it
it's really messy I don't actually like
it so when I was coming through the back
door I was like holy [ __ ] the last time
I was here the last time I played here I
played a couple nights like by myself QA
and Alan Rickman came to one of the
night so it was anybody here for the
Alan Rickman night so I didn't dream
that [ __ ] you were there oh it was
[ __ ] lovely him and Reema his lady
both came to see the show he liked
obviously I loved him and I've spoken
about in many places his stuff but in
order to set the table I'll say a few
things about the great Alan Rickman we
got lucky enough to work with him in
Dogma at the end of dogma like I was
like oh my god I can't believe we worked
with the great Alan Rickman and Alan
Rickman like wanted my contacts he's
like give me your information we'll keep
in touch and I'm like oh that's what
people say at the end of the movie I
said that to Affleck and I haven't
spoken to obsess I was like that's just
a movie thing to say but he legit was
like interested in me as like a friend
like oh his [ __ ] heart breaking the
day I realized like oh my god he
actually likes me this isn't like him
being polite because we worked together
once 10 years ago like he's legit
interested in my [ __ ] life any time
he was in the States he would like call
up and be like I'm here in the States as
your duty to show me around and [ __ ] and
so we'd go out and then any time I was
here he would call me again like it was
a real one-way street and not because I
was like ill Alan
Rickman's on the phone I never thought
to call him that would be like me
thinking to call like you know [ __ ] I
don't know Jesus and be like let's
[ __ ] hang out when I go to London you
know like I just assumed he's busy
living his life and [ __ ] but no matter
whenever I came over he always call up
find me
he found me the trip that I was over
here and my home telephone rang and said
hello and I thought is back in the days
pre cellphone this predates [ __ ]
texting and [ __ ] like that so I answered
the goddamn phones I would never do that
today
and answered the phone and as hello and
he goes is this Kevin Smith them and I
was like oh my god it's you and he goes
why weren't you cold
he's like you've been here for three
days I'm not gonna do the accent he's
like you've been here for three days you
haven't called and I was like I was
working and I just assumed you were
working too and he goes well I want to
come see your show I've heard from so
many people that they've gone to see you
I want to come see you speak so oh my
god I can hook you up with three tickets
he goes I hope they're free
great actor fifty man sure so he came
and watched the show and sat I want to
say [ __ ] like cuz he was dead sent
like where it was up so that's yeah in
the front of this level that's right
[ __ ] you remember better than me my
stone than you are that's what I'm
guessing
well my perspective was like I wasn't
sitting back then I was standing so I
remember like being able to see him and
down here I just assumed it was it but
you're right he was on the second floor
and I was standing the whole night so he
was always within eyeshot periodically
I'd [ __ ] look at him and she was
doing the stories and he after you know
I didn't I didn't single Matt or
anything like that and then at the end
of the [ __ ] night he like we drove
back together to town because you know
it's I don't know if you know this but
it's a [ __ ] hundred hours to London
at the centre of town so we got in a car
was me and Jennifer and him and Rima and
stuff and I was like would you think of
the show and he was doing you were very
funny but I gotta say I loved being at
your show tonight and I was like oh why
didn't get that a lot of people are like
oh I like to see you in your element or
something like but his thing bless you
his thing he goes like I loved being at
your show tonight
because everybody there knew who I was
all of your fans came over and says
there's wonderful things and took
pictures and stuff and this is again
before the cellphone so these are
pictures like with cameras actual
[ __ ] cameras and [ __ ] where people
put a drape over their back and go like
that the big flash of old-timey [ __ ] so
it was so [ __ ] sweet it's such a
really nice memory of driving back with
him and him talking about the show like
he was like it's so he did say it was
like really nice to see you stand up
there and just talk and stuff he's going
because in the movie you don't do that
at all and I was like oh my god you're
right he goes when you think about it
they owe you an award and I was like why
are you guys cuz it really takes a
performance for you not to talk you're
always talking and then also when we
were [ __ ] driving back he goes that
was the thing I've said the story verba
if I could love it he goes obviously you
go I'll see you a lot more lately
because I just bought a flat in London I
was like we don't call it that it's an
apartment he goes I bought an apartment
in New York he said as I get out of here
in [ __ ] New York man where and he's
going he said where it was and I said
that's [ __ ] awesome I go to New York
way more than I ever come to London and
stuff and he was getting ready to do
this is Rachel Corrie as a play I think
I'm a Broadway at that point so he was
gonna be there for a long period of time
and so he was like I said where did you
where is it and he told me where it was
and I was like oh there's a building
there he's like this brand new building
there and I bought an apartment there
because my friend told me about the
building he has an apartment there and I
was like who's your friend and he goes
right fiends
and I was like holy [ __ ] he goes that's
right yeah he's gone Voldemort and Snape
live in the same building and neighbors
he goes we can't let the Potter fans
find out they'll tumble it to the ground
so sweet I miss him but last last time I
was here I left with him that tonight
I'll be leaving with Ralph same same
quality performers by your size same
gender
[Applause]
towns I wasn't here ever this is my
first time here in the indigo but thank
you so much but I have been to the big
room because last time we came out here
to do Hollywood babble-on you may
remember one of the reasons I pushed so
hard for that tours because Monty Python
was also reuniting to perform at the o2
so I got to see them here and that was
one of the great thrills what how was
that a long show you know they did all
the greatest hits they did spam and
nudge know did you feel like you were a
kid again yeah it was it was like being
a it was in comedy heaven watching those
guys will Time Machine yeah
so this this part of the world has great
memories for me I did something today
that I've never done I rarely get a
chance to talk about new [ __ ] that's
happened to me and stuff and generally
whenever we do a show I go from like the
hotel to the car to the venue but today
I went on an adventure Dom who was such
a help to us worked with Jason Mewes on
a movie that Jason directed both in the
States and over here
it's called method madness and the
method am i right tom
thank you and Jason directed a great
[ __ ] job like everybody he knows
isn't it pulled in a lot of cool people
in [ __ ] and so when we did Jay and
Silent Bob reboot Dom was there because
he liked you know Jay and Silent Bob and
see like the view askew movie so he was
like if you guys are making that movie
could I come and hang out and so oh my
god absolutely about it ball means Dom
wound up being like a [ __ ] like an
asset to the production not just
somebody who showed up to like watch the
show which is always nice but he
actually is like I love Jay and Silent
Bob reboot the movie that we just
finished making for those unfamiliar I
made a sequel to Jay and Silent Bob
strike back
and the movie is entitled Jay and Silent
Bob reboot and I'm in love with it it's
my favorite thing I've ever done if I
die tomorrow I'm okay now cuz I'm like
[ __ ] no I'm cool
okay we've been through that one but I'd
be okay because this really speaks for
the life this speaks for the whole
career and the life it's really turned
into a great flick funniest [ __ ] but
also just this really warm thing so on
day one of production when we got there
first day we had nine pages of dialogue
to shoot and that's a lot and that's
between me Jason Mewes and Jason Lee
who's playing Brody the character that
he played in Mallrats and Jay and Silent
Bob strike back as well so nine [ __ ]
page and to be fair it's not between the
three of us because Silent Bob has no
done yes so it's not baited true the two
of them and Jason Mewes as the heavier
lifting because he has to set up the
whole movie it's the scene in which we
introduced the premise and whatnot and
the premise of the movie is vastly
different than the movie that were
sequel izing if you remember Jay and
Silent Bob strike back that was a movie
in which Jay and Silent Bob found out
that Hollywood was making a movie based
on them and so they ran across country
to stop Hollywood from making that movie
and stuff and that was fine for 2001 and
[ __ ] but it's 2019 and I'd like to think
that I've grown as a filmmaker hence
that walrus picture yeah and and I've
learned a few things and so I could
never [ __ ] make that movie again so
the sequel with the Jay and Silent Bob
reboot is its name is completely
different than the movie that its base
equalizing in that movie Jay and Silent
Bob find out that Hollywood is making a
reboot of that old movie about oh I see
and then they travel back to Hollywood
to stop it all over again it's the same
[ __ ] movie all over again
it's my little film school experiment
see if I get paid twice for the same
[ __ ] movie smart so while we're doing
that we're doing the scene with Brody
and that sets up the plot where they
boys find out in this scene that hey
they're making a reboot of that old
movie look what and this is the movie
where the scene where we decide we have
to go back to Hollywood and stuff so
first day nine pages this is a movie
we've been getting ready to make for two
[ __ ] years and stuff and I've been
ready
oh I've been so [ __ ] ready man I
looked for all the directions a possible
bullet could come from that might
[ __ ] you know hit me I wasn't
expecting that I was prepared [ __ ] I've
been making movies at this point for 25
[ __ ] years so I'm like nothing's
gonna get [ __ ] past me right thank
you
the old pro that being said there was a
bullet and it came from Jason Mewes the
guy standing next to me Jason was
ill-prepared for our first day of
shooting he didn't memorize nine pages
of dialogue oh that's what he did was
Jason's philosophy was like you know it
been about let me see to his credit 2006
since we've done a movie together as Jay
and Silent Bob and to be fair we were
only in about 25% of that movie so
technically it's been 18 years since
he's done a Jay and Silent Bob movie
where he's the sole [ __ ] lead and
stuff and when you're in like the lead
of a movie is one thing from being in
the lead in the Kevin Smith movie
because in Kevin Smith movie is the lead
you say ridiculous amounts of [ __ ]
he's a wordy [ __ ] okay that
writer he's so verbose but you know you
come prepared Jason Lee he hadn't acted
in four years he came prepared and [ __ ]
do all his dialogue and whatnot Jason
Mewes had gotten used to since our time
together just going to a set and
memorizing the day's work while he was
in the makeup chair because he's like
I've been doing this for 20 years now or
whatever the [ __ ] and then you know
ready to go but he didn't realize that
like bro you've got three monologues
that are four pages long like you can't
just memorize even one of those the
morning of like you got to put in the
work so day 1 was tough man it was real
heavy lifting and [ __ ] and I was like
look I understand what's wrong and all
the other productions I spent time with
him like just drill and dialogue but I
didn't have that time on this production
and Plus like he was a kid when we used
to do that [ __ ] and he's like [ __ ]
middle-aged learn your [ __ ] lines and
[ __ ] you know so I was but he needs
somebody to drill lines with him so Dom
was there and I was like Dom just
[ __ ] drill lines with Jay Jay he's
way comfortable with Dom and stuff just
I need you to just constantly run lines
of them that could never happen again
he's always got to know his [ __ ]
lines and stuff and that never happened
to get day 2 was a hundred and eighty
degree turn from Jason he knew always
knew his dialogue
like the day in advance so whatever we
were shooting he knew the next day is
dialogue as well
he became overly prepared he learned
from his mistake and completely self
corrected without browbeating and [ __ ]
like that he's really great but Dom was
the guy that would drill dialogue with
him every [ __ ] day and there was a
vast difference between day one and day
two when Dom was able to just sit there
and Jason just needed somebody to run
dialogue with and also somebody who
understood the script Dom did Jason
really didn't he was like why are we
doing this again and I'm like didn't
you've read the [ __ ] script he's like
just my parts so Dom read the script and
appreciated it and would explain
concepts of Jason where Jason was like
oh like and that's what made it funny
and for him and he could give a better
performance so Dom is like you know in
the hill we'll have some sort of [ __ ]
credit in the movie but you'll mean
every angler yeah maybe but you'll never
know like what I mean you will and now
folks on the podcast will know that like
like it wasn't just like man who he
helped out like Jason's performance
bounces off of Dom whenever I was not on
camera when I was like off camera
because I'm the director and I was like
it's in order for us to go fast I should
watch the scene because Silent Bob's not
really in it it's more just his shoulder
or something like that Jason would be
like can Dom do it give him the coat and
so when you watch the movie
sometimes it's Dom little piece of down
then there's no piece Dom as opposed to
like silent Kevin silent Dom and [ __ ]
like that so it was a boon to the
production man and so today Dom saved me
again
because apparently as you said the
center of London was shut down a car
ride out here was gonna be three hours
and was gonna make me like an hour late
for the [ __ ] show and they were like
or you could take the tube and I've
never taken the tube in my line oh yeah
because I [ __ ] grew up watching
American Werewolf in London so [ __ ] that
man I've been [ __ ] the tube I couldn't
get down the [ __ ] elevator the
escalator the stairs like all that was
terrifying enough but they're like Dom
will bring you you know
folks here like Dom's gonna escort she's
gonna get you to the to
and they'll get you on the tube and
they'll get you to us and if you do that
you're gonna be there in 25 minutes like
otherwise you're gonna sit in the car
for three hours is 25 minutes in
possible Hell or three hours in the back
of a car and it's not hell because it's
easy everybody does it I was like I know
but I've never I don't even take the
subway in New York man like [ __ ] this
will be new for me and [ __ ] like Dom
will protect you so in Dom we trust and
I do so as I got you know what if it's
Dom I'll [ __ ] go for it so I smoked a
[ __ ] ton of weed because I was like this
the only way I'm gonna brave this [ __ ]
because the whole time I'm like you know
what it's either either content for a
podcast or I'm gonna die either one
which would be content for my podcast
would be great somebody's gonna get a
story at exactly so we [ __ ] marched to
the [ __ ] underground I've seen that
sign forever and I've heard it referred
to I've seen it in movies and [ __ ] like
that but you know that term the tube
like I always thought was like oh it's
like the colloquial ism because you're
in a you know if the tunnel is a [ __ ]
tumor and [ __ ] I've been in one New York
subway car and to be fair it was fairly
spacious and she I wouldn't want to live
there but but there is some room and
whatnot we got in this [ __ ] tube bro
I mean they're not [ __ ] around it is
literally a - there's no irony in the
name whatsoever it's like [ __ ] like
getting mugged down here we're all gonna
die in this - no no oh my god it is so
small there's no seating and [ __ ] like
that and I was like we're gonna do this
for 25 minutes and they're like yeah
yeah it's gonna go by like that and I'm
like people do this all the time like
yeah I'm like there's no [ __ ] space
they can't build this bigger they're
like [ __ ] history above us bro you
can't just go building tunnels and [ __ ]
America is only two minutes old and [ __ ]
you still expect an American high isn't
it bigger and why doesn't it have a
buffet I would like us I would like a
spread of foods when I come in here
dishes and then maybe just some cold
cuts and cheeses over here I asked him I
was like is there like a bar car or
something like that and he's like no
it's the tube man
and I was like do they have bar cars in
Subway's those are I'll take the subways
in New York and so yeah there's no sorry
there was no food either but it was what
an interesting experience man it went by
so [ __ ] fast I don't know honestly
and I know like he's probably blushing
but I don't know I would have gotten
through it without Dom it was confusing
his [ __ ] man mercifully he was like go
here go here put it in there take back
go this way and if I can March me
through the whole thing so like every
step of the way I was like anything you
say DOM and we were here in like a half
an hour is [ __ ] nuts like people and
it's like not on the subway in New York
when I was on the subway in Newark and
this was years ago Ilana be up before I
had a career or anything like that
people were just like hey hey hey [ __ ]
you [ __ ] like that we're like alright
are you alright [ __ ] me [ __ ] me there
was none of that here like nobody even
talked to us I would not have people and
they were like harem none of this they
don't want any of that and [ __ ] like
that I figured I have busy going
someplace they had things to do they
were all looking at make is the like
what's with the hat and the [ __ ] are
those jeans or shorts they're jorts what
are what is you know they would look at
you because you're going this really is
a - where are the seats I kept trying to
make eye contact as I was like where do
you buy the snack I mean we're on this
thing for 25 minutes where's the
restaurant it was pretty cool no well
back to the real world sir
thank you the American Werewolf in
London totally [ __ ] lied like that
wait a minute a movie didn't reflect
true life I know the heck you say it's
the thing that I always hear about quick
stop when people go to visit the Kwik
Stop in real life right they're like oh
my god it's so much smaller in real life
than it looks
in the movie you know my class because
the movies like you know a movie and
[ __ ] and also like we're shooting at an
angle where the stores it's like the
selling point angle if it was a dick pic
it makes the [ __ ] rent convenience
store the best looking dick right you
know it's the right [ __ ] angle and
[ __ ]
so this like when I went in I was like
oh it don't look like the movie at all I
mean it wasn't the same stop and [ __ ]
but it
[ __ ] tighter and I was like oh my god
it looks so much bigger in the [ __ ]
movie like the same people to say the
same [ __ ] like to me about clerks in him
I was like yes whole cuz it was in the
movie and [ __ ] I'm the [ __ ] Ralph I
was gonna say you took the words out of
my mouth but it was awesome man I've did
something really new this time around
it's very efficient especially if you
dealt with traffic in in London it
really gets you around we're not taking
a back though [ __ ] that night it's
probably telling that kevin has to be
helicoptered out of here tonight I don't
know that means anything right now
they're gonna pick him up by a drone and
drop him off in front of his hotel on a
[ __ ] rope ladder that's great so
anyway we were talking about Jay and
Silent Bob reboot man and you know I it
would be remiss of me to like just talk
about it and not share a little bit with
you I think word is out some folks have
been talking that some folks saw a
little clip from the movie earlier in
the tour I brought the most relevant
clip of the movie I possibly could the
one that features my good friend Ralph
Garman
so the entirety of my performance will
be seen tonight by you people which is
not a bad thing to see the arc of my
character it's a movie full of cameos
that don't last very long right stuff
like that some longer than others
yes burn bright and then you know fizzle
out right so the movie though I'd like
to give a perspective Jay and Silent Bob
strike back at the end we did photo
credits like a people breaking character
and looking like they're having a good
time Cannonball Run type exactly so we
had 22 cards at the end of Jay and
Silent Bob strike back
oh here's join too [ __ ] famous people
and [ __ ] this one without one we shot in
Los Angeles so it made sense that we got
like that cast and and also that what I
was coming off of dogmas of people like
he's the future of cinema now I'm at the
end so so it was like way easier to
fetch cast and [ __ ] like that back then
we were like turning people away on that
one so on this one it was like I'll [ __ ]
who we gonna get and [ __ ]
and I'm happy to report that we have 44
cards at the end of this movie like and
like these are legit
stars which is awesome Amy and I also am
in it yes you rub elbows that's true
with some real [ __ ] famous people
it's cool man all of them came out and
they came to New Orleans which is pretty
far from like Los Angeles but all of
them came out and did pieces and man to
a woman each one of them when they were
done they were like I'm happy you're
still alive
and then they'd leave and that was their
way of saying like don't call me again
this was the one you get one heart boy
but I used as best I could man I was
like if I'm only getting one I'm gonna
call on everything and so oh it's it's
it was a wonderful walk down memory lane
for me everyone that I've worked with
over the course of quarter century like
I got to play with again it was really
sweet so I brought the scene tonight
featuring [ __ ] Ralph just to set up
where it happens in the movie as I said
before the in the Brody scene that's
when Jay and Silent Bob find out that
the movie happening and they decide to
go to Hollywood again and that's like
happens about the 15 17 minute mark or
something like that
so then we go to the airport and there's
a scene at the airport that then leads
to what you're about to see and at the
end of that scene at the airport
the boys are taught about a rideshare
it's a concept they were not familiar
with and stuff we don't do Ober or
anything like that because [ __ ] paying
them so I made up a rideshare company
and it's called ride me now and so so
the boys have just found out they can
take ride me now cross-country if they
wanted to and they've downloaded the app
but of course you know if you're gonna
use that you need a credit card and
these two guys of course do not have a
credit card so that's where the scene
takes place one last thing I'll say is
please don't record this we're trying to
keep it [ __ ] on the down-low don't
want anybody spoiling it throwing up
online and stuff like that
this is for you guys because you pay it
in you're here in person so yeah enjoy
so be selfish yeah a bit to yourself
we'll be cutting it out of the podcast
as well they'll hear everything right up
until this point and then just some of
the clips about to begin we'll probably
leave the start of
clip-in justly holy [ __ ] and then [ __ ]
you know we gotta make fart sound effect
in there or something during that it's
all time yeah that's how to make friends
but uh so anyway this is just for the
folks here in the room if you see
somebody surreptitiously videotaping it
or videotaping this it's not the 80s
using their phone and trying to shoot it
man just be like don't hit him it's not
a trump rally but just like tell him
like hey man [ __ ] don't do that he
said not to and he just had a heart
attack and he came all this way and what
say oh yeah boy do you throw some of
that British common sense it on the Jag
yeah bit of that oil if I get a hearse
you live here I guess they're calling it
out they're like all right so here we go
man this is nobody's really seen
anything of the movie anywhere we never
this is I the clip I've only brought
here since we've been doing the shows
but nobody's seen in the States or
anything like that and we won't be doing
it at the Babylon at home and [ __ ] so
this is just for you guys
movie comes out it looks like in the
fall because I'm gonna come back and be
with it and stuff like that Universal
has it over here and stuff so without
further ado a scene from Jay and Silent
Bob reboot featuring the great Ralph
Karma it's didn't those lights and watch
a little you're too kind
oh stop in in many ways you make the
whole movie possible your character if I
don't give up that credit card
information you guys aren't going know
exactly so there it is Ben yeah it
Universal has it and I'll be back in the
fall with Jay and we'll be talking about
it and showing it and stuff like that
awesome can't wait to share it with you
thank you for that that was awesome
that's a great reaction yeah it was now
I'm keeping it in the movie wait a
minute there was a question without a
fence there's ways to get around it son
of a [ __ ] they liked it enough where I
take back everything I said at the top
of this yeah all right let's get things
kicked off here when Hollywood babble-on
the way we usually do most of our
episodes by talking to you kind folks
out there in the audience who have come
to join us tonight people are
celebrating special occasions or have
come particularly long distances it's a
segment we call the shout outs
[Music]
[Music]
get your [ __ ] out goodness it's weird
without the [ __ ] wire yeah no I was
at an absolute loss man this must be
what it's like when you encounter like
an uncut dick in your life more of a
European cut if you will it's do people
circumcise their kids anymore are you
cut here in the UK it is not a not a
custom so even in the 70s it wasn't
happened like in this like I was born in
1970 we were born when I was born 1960s
and you were cut yes that was the one it
was in vogue when everybody's I cut your
kids it's still the norm in the United
States is it really yeah hmm but heroes
never the know has never the Norton so
here it's always like a wizard sleeve
it's not a wizard sleeve it's more like
a snake in a nice Aachen why is the head
all twisted why is that
you got Peyronie's syndrome oh it's
gnarled oh my god it's the talking
British penis that's a new kid show it's
gonna be on the fall here let's see
who's up first
Steve greening are you here Steve
greening where make some noise it's a
[ __ ] podcast what is there is that
you Steve alright I calm down Steve
you're way too excited
we found you man this is like Where's
Waldo pick someone else
Steve says hi Kevin Ralph welcome back
to the UK steve has a request could
president Donald Trump sing his version
of the Divinyls I touch myself
I'll be shooting that on my phone for
the FBI back home this has been such a
nice week to leave all that behind I
know and now Steve is putting it back in
my face again so to speak
all right u.s. president Donald Trump's
singing the classic by the Divinyls I
touch myself
I love myself okay
I want you to love me when I feel down I
want me about me a bit I search myself I
want you to find me I forget myself I
want me to remind me I'm the best touch
of myself out of everybody touching of
myself my little mushroom penis all
right that's enough of that and mushroom
penis thing still gets me crazy
forgotten until you brought it back out
oh yeah
Christopher judge are you here tonight
tonight it's the night of like yes
tentatively your green-themed are trying
to get through you know you're on your
own my friend I can tell by the way
you're staring off knowledge even though
I'm sitting next to you campaign when
wouldn't you thought oh Jesus next
you're gonna start talking brexit and
then we're really [ __ ] now we'll stick
to American politics
Christopher judge writes myself my
hetero life mate Matt and our friends
orally and and Jermaine will all be
attending your show were they all here
yeah see your friends are loud
Christopher did he pronounced that right
orally Ellie which one oh really oh
really oh so he didn't pronounce it
right at all oh really she said oh
really you were like it's orally in the
house some drunk dad was like yeah I'm
here
oh really is that how it said yeah yeah
forgot how Continental you are mister
look at this what is that from that's
that you got an accent is that French
French very very pretty word what does
it mean do you know yeah [ __ ] Orly
what does it mean she's down there by
the way what do you keep looking up
there for how high are you hearing
voices from all over the theatre they're
right over there where raise your hand
real good
so orally so what does that mean did you
think I was looking down my nose at you
I don't know what was going on
Bonjour yeah there we go
Christopher rides been a fan of Kevin's
ever since watching clerks on a bootleg
VHS you got no money for that one sucker
Schubert a time years later man that's
right I was introduced around through
HBO and I've been a fan ever since Ralph
you're my fan cast for Perry White in a
Superman reboot I'll take that yeah why
don't you reboot Superman give me a job
if it was that easy believe me I would
all right [ __ ] I make you Perry White
I'd play Lex Luthor kind of fun right
yeah sure Jason Mewes would play the
Giants by that's right we are a diverse
crew from Hong Kong France Cyprus and
England Wow
what's Cyprus
[Applause]
he asked very continentally yes Orly
please tell him a while suppressants is
that is that in France stop looking up
[Applause]
calm down I'm guessing she's not the one
from Cyprus she's probably the one from
France which one which one of your
friends is from Cyprus Christopher
Christopher you're from Cyprus oh okay
tell him where it is Christopher is not
very loud Christopher where is where is
it
it's a Greek island oh okay all right
there's the more you know
yeah I've been brushed up on my Greek
islands lately in today's troubled times
writes Christopher could the Germans
please teach us the importance of
friendship between the nations well who
better to talk to than people from a
country that invented world war 1 in
World War 2 so absolutely
not Nazis people of Churchill I'm still
angry Willis Devore so you are from a
Cyprus and you are from France and
you're from England and Hong Kong
there's several of the allies in there I
don't like that
it feels so feared to do this bit
it's alright day one where the losers
what have we got nothing we got
Volkswagen that's it
it's so much easier to do this bit in
Los Angeles where there was no World War
two actually happening that's true
no no Sarah made movies about World War
Two there John Wayne yeah get that you
Krauts you would say so you are from
Cyprus he's a Cypriot that's what they
call people from Cyprus
once again and you're very smart
yeah yeah yeah very multicultural like
us better time add yeah dude it helps
out here Benetton yeah ok I couldn't
tell from your reaction that was 9 it's
the board like a 7 year 7 perhaps yeah
you already see this is the most
important thing for all the peoples from
other nations to spend time together 6 9
9 section hourly sex not in Harley sex
where she yeah oh this is a good one
tawny white from Hitchin Tony are you
here that's it that's how you do it
Christopher like that guy right there
Tony writes a bit of fan of the show for
years I'll be tending Hollywood
babble-on with my 62 year old mother
Jill is know where she is hi Jill
hi Jill oh my god this is adorable are
you familiar with this show at all no it
says right here in the email she has no
idea who you were Kevin are so I thought
it'd be a good idea to show her some
smut and dick jokes on a Wednesday night
for some d-list celebrities yes you're a
good son at least you set her up
properly she doesn't get to go out to
London as much as she used to and she
doesn't get to shake her stuff with a
fella out in the town very often
she is mad as a bag of spanners and
always used to be the life of the party
so could sexy Kevin please give this
wonderful woman a few tips on what she
should get up to now that she has a few
hours to do whatever the [ __ ] she wants
in the big city
there you go sexy keV I want you to tell
62 year old Jill what she can get up to
tonight in old London town let's get a
little music for Kevin shall we here we
go oh
I know of an American guy who let you
[ __ ] them in the ass tonight and good ol
Underdown that'll be one worth telling
people back home do you ever hear of a
guy named Ralphie I [ __ ] it sound like
me listen while you're here in London
what you need to find is respect you're
a 62 year old mother that's all you
should be looking for good times are a
thing of the past
oh that's depressing [ __ ] you started
with s [ __ ] they didn't take it
anywhere you wanna [ __ ] this guy over at
the local hotel that's all I got
oh my goodness sexy Kevin how dare you
[ __ ] the sexy part how adorable is this
man you took your mom to a gig I do that
all the time and stuff but it's always
my gig so it's kind of the same thing
but my mom loves it cuz she's like oh I
love Kevin Smith he came out of my [ __ ]
I'm sorry Joe I just want to make sure
they knew exactly where I came in
yeah how sweet that's awesome man dude
continue to do stuff with your mom I do
it all the time when my favorite things
in the world to do with my mother is
when we go back to Jersey that's where
we were both from we get really blazed
and we drive around to every place that
ever mattered where I grew up and I tell
her about it and it's like pornography
for her because she's like oh my god he
remembers everything I was a good mother
so I'm gonna prove this big-time man
this that's [ __ ] dope
do you think for a minute that Jill will
ever let her son take her out again
after tonight ever happening I think
they bond over this she's just like this
is the kind of shot you're into no boy
all right Louise pepper are you were
here tonight and Louise coming to the
show with my friend Bobby he introduced
me to the podcast several years ago and
I became such an avid fan that it was
playing in the delivery room when I had
my daughter earlier this year Wow
Hollywood babble-on in the delivery room
while you were having your daughter
it's horrible choice yes I have to say
did it take your mind off of what was
going on why are you looking up there
again she's back there is up there sorry
what what why that one and then the
birth
she said that it's induced laughter
helps induce labor but by the time we
got to the Justin Bieber part of the
show the Midwife was like what the [ __ ]
are we listening to yeah it's awesome
man oh my god we're a part of your
family's DNA a little bit your genealogy
if we were their kind of Louise says she
was laughing so hard on the mix of
Babylon and gas and air that she almost
kicked the Midwife doing her stitches in
the head would probably suit if that
happens this is my first time coming to
London since she was born in January and
leaving my three-month-old daughter for
the first time and thus resulting in an
angry baby and the painful endurance of
to no doubt rock-solid leaking boobs oh
my god did that happen yet yeah are they
leaking now I think he wants to know we
can get you complimentary t-shirts it's
got me in Ralph's faces to cover the
nipples that's right we look like we're
crying she has the weeping Christ on her
chest
it's a miracle the weeping babble this
is your first time away from the kids
since kid was born oh my god I know the
exact [ __ ] feeling this is the first
week I've had away from the movie since
we finished it and that's my baby you
know and that's why your boobs are
rock-hard watch this leaky - that's
right it's my birthday in a couple of
weeks and if David Bowie could sing me
happy birthday it would make my year
writes Louise well of course we could do
that for you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're leaking out of a whole nother
part of your body all right we also get
emails from all around the world
[Music]
featuring Kevin's reactions that's right
this first one oh this is very
appropriate we have a segment on the
show where people write in lyrics that
they've been singing their whole lives
to popular songs and they just recently
found out they're dumb shits and I love
that makes me laugh very hard this one
comes from a guy named Bob Williams and
I tell you the lyric first I'm
explaining to you what he thought it was
all about then we'll play the song he
thought this song from 1979 was about
the fact that it was the disco air the
end of the disco era and people at
discos the music was so loud and
something that they couldn't talk to
each other anymore
and he thought the lyrics to the song
were disco phonic so we don't talk
anymore here's the song
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
some of you can see that one bad stretch
man he must have been in a disco
listening to that and he couldn't hear
it from 79 so what is the logic of that
disco phonic so we don't talk anymore
right the music is so loud that no one
in bars was talking to each other
because the disco music was so loud it's
actually oddly poetic it's also from the
UK Peter in Oxford sent this in there
are folks who run across towns places
streets lakes that have [ __ ] up names
and so we created a segment called your
towns got a fucked-up name
[Music]
Peter said this one end has a mention
distance from a street in a nearby town
and he lives there in Oxford and Kevin
this is a legitimate place here is the
here's the sign for the street oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] shoot close which sounds like
Tarzan getting near an orgasm [ __ ] shoot
close slow down Jane me one last shoot
[ __ ] shoot closed signs like a painful
[ __ ] medical condition of course we
always take a look at things that people
send you that are meant for kids as well
these are stuff that's made for boys and
girls to enjoy and then when you take a
long hard look at them you realize they
are inappropriate toys
[Music]
this first one is from I wonder if he's
here tonight say it was coming but maybe
he is Ben Ripley by any chance has been
here tonight been here yeah Ben calls
himself the South London Silent Bob
you'll be hearing from my attorneys here
do you do you cosplay as the Silent Bob
you do blunt man yeah Oh real at the
mock Comic Con thing right the [ __ ] on
we took a picture together [ __ ] a man
why don't you come over when we made
that movie we needed you let a bunch of
people look like me it was awesome it's
your favorite Dave it was oh my god it
was like being John Malkovich day Ben
sent this one in at first glance this
seems like an innocuous children's book
it looks kind of cute it's called my
daddy is a giant oh it's not adorable
yeah the only problem with this book is
you have to be very careful how you put
it in the shelves at a bookstore then
run across this picture it's not for
kids really when it's boy daddy's a [ __ ]
you guarantee you he was so disappointed
when he got to the book is a giant sauce
my daddy's a [ __ ] [ __ ] that would
sell more than go the [ __ ] to sleep I
think so my daddy's a [ __ ] brandy in
North Carolina back in the States sent
this and this is a business nearby her
apparently that deals it's a consignment
store I don't know what you would call
it here but people take their clothes
there and they sell them especially kids
clothes because your kids grow out of
them instead of thrown away or give them
away you take them to a consignment
store charity shop there you go you can
make a few bucks thank you so I'm
struggling and drowning there and she
was like Joey shop move on this place is
called the kids exchange however when
you look at the sign
it might be inappropriate to take your
kids to the kids sex change location I'm
not judging maybe your kid knows already
but on this hand
seems inappropriate to me I hope they
got a discount man like you don't think
there should be more space in that now
it's fine Fitz everyone knows what you
mean this one came from Brandon Dalton
this is our last one this isn't
necessarily inappropriate but it sure is
[ __ ] stupid
Brandon ran across this as his kid was
watching YouTube videos and you know the
kids that's what they do instead of
television I know my kid does she
watches YouTube instead and so the
little kids were learning all the stuff
little kids learn especially in the
States the nursery rhymes and the songs
that all kids know like Old MacDonald
had a farm you know that one right yeah
i ee i oh
Brandon's kid was watching this and
Brandon said this was inappropriate
because not because it's rude but
because it's going to make his kid
[ __ ] stupid so I'm going to show you
the video and then we'll talk about it
Old MacDonald had a farm eieio and on
that farm he had a horse eieio what does
a horse say what does the horse say the
horse says I'm a [ __ ] zebra that's
what the horse is how did that get
passed no fancy horse yeah them fancy
stripe aid horses Jesus Christ it also
looks like the tractor was about to hit
an animal at the end of the clip yeah it
was a dog and of course it is common
knowledge by now that I am confused by
Japan I don't understand them I don't
know why they like what they do I'm just
perplexed and so I respectfully ask
every week what the [ __ ] Japan
what the [ __ ] Japan this week's what the
[ __ ] Japan comes from Kimi DeLeon she
recently bought a toy from a Japanese
store it's from a company called dye
Seoul and it is a toy baby doll well you
can see the kids love to play with baby
dolls but what's not to love about this
only this isn't just a baby doll toy
it's actually a water pistol or a squirt
gun as we say in the States
now how would that cute little baby boy
be a squirt gun let me show you come on
the box says you're in for a lot of fun
I will when I get back to America I'll
file it what kid needs a baby pissing on
it as a toy why is that a thing it at
the kids sex-change place oh I guess so
yeah it's a good idea we also like to
say goodbye to some folks in show
business who left us recently but left
behind bodies of work to will enjoy for
many years to come it's a segment we
call the tinsel town stiffs oh there's
that toy again squirt the dog in the
face with the pissing baby now that's
one way to have fun with it what clip is
that death meant to signify the death of
common sense the dog attacked the owner
and mauled him to death for pissing in
his face
now another edition of
[Music]
they will be missed they will indeed
Peggy Lipton passed away this week most
of you probably know her best I'm
guessing for her work on Twin Peaks but
she was also a big star in the United
States on a late 60s early 70s cop show
with three young undercover cops called
the Mod Squad and there she is with her
co-stars on that show that made her a
big star and then she took a bunch of
time off to raise her kids and she came
back to work in a big way with David
Lynch in the late 1980s 1989 to be exact
on a series called Twin Peaks where she
played Norma Jennings owner of the
Double R diner and a dental of that show
so much what year was Matt's claudin
from 1968 to 1973 I would have had a
completely different meaning over here
Maude was a different thing here like
the mom in the 60s Yeah right here's a
little scene from Twin Peaks featuring
the late
Peggy Lipton who passed away at the age
of 72 this week she in this scene is
talking to what was the match anemic
character on that show
the waitress used to work for her was
married to Leo Shelley thank you so much
yeah Shelley's gonna leave her job at
the Double R because Leo's back and he's
a vegetable pretty much she has to take
care of him full-time yeah so here she
is telling Norman that she's going to be
leaving her job look Shelly if your own
life to worry about
[Music]
are you sure yes and you look after
yourself when you're ready you can come
right back I'd just be like you haven't
even missed a day you'll let me come
back just try to take a job someplace
else and see what happens
[Music]
72 years old Peggy Lipton huge bucket a
win she was the anchor for that show in
a lot of ways for me because she was
always the sweet normal sort of motherly
character to a lot of the other
characters when everyone else was sort
of a lunatic you know she had a real
ethereal quality about her very much
self dreamy as she was suffering from
colon cancer and finally succumb this
week so 7 is and then we also lost a
Hollywood legend Doris Day passed away
this week at the age of 97 huge mountain
of when Lord a star on so many levels
she was a recording artist in the late
40s first and had a ton of hits and then
Hollywood came a-callin as they say and
they put her in movies and she was a
successful singer she to calamity jane
the musical that was her first big sort
of breakthrough role and then she became
known for being the star of a whole slew
of romantic comedies in the late 50s and
early 60s a sort of defined her career
and she got sort of a bad rap she was
known as being too wholesome and too
virginal you know in the 60s there was a
cultural shift where that sort of
entertainment fell out of favor and she
became obsolete and she went to
television later on in the 60s and 70s
but her film career was never quite what
it was again she's one of those names
that's like synonymous though with
superstardom yes you know like Steven
Spielberg is the director name that
everybody on the planet knows Doris Day
is a name that everybody knew even from
maybe not this generation as much but
when we were growing up she was even
though she was older she was still super
and she worked with all of the big
actors of the day Cary Grant he did a
couple of films with James Garner one of
my favorites but she probably stored as
Jimmy Stewart yeah without Fred
Hitchcock and the man who knew too much
but her big breakthrough in terms of
romantic comedies probably came with her
to film she did with Rock Hudson back in
the late 50s early 60s including pillow
talk
we sort of invented that genre of
romantic comedy and it was very
influential for its style as well as
very stylistically directed you remember
that scene where they're talking on the
telephone in separate rooms but they do
a split screen that is sort of the wall
between their two tubs going back and we
lay the first one they were the first
ones to do that yeah and I brought that
in tonight as we say goodbye to Doris
Day every time I look at you I say to
myself we got all kinds of natural
resources back home the we got nothing
like that stay something else too I kind
of hated New York when I first came here
all those papers seem so distant no
don't feel that way man that's good
show turned out to be friendly title
you'll find that most people are willing
to meet you halfway
if you listen Wow class she was classy
as a film by my friend Peyton Reed who
of course directed the ant-man movie but
he did sunk 'old down with love it's
very much an homage to those kind of
films and he does if that kind of split
screen thing to as tribute to that film
97 years old he can't hardly ask for
more than that really and they said she
was in really good health right up until
she died then she was in not good health
I guess at that point that's where
health usually takes a turn that usually
where it does yeah at the grave yes now
she got pneumonia apparently a bad case
of pneumonia that's what took her life
but she's big animal booster spent the
remaining years of her life when she
left show business being a full-time
animal activist she opened up a little
Inn up in Northern California where
every day instead of happy hour they
would have yappy hour and you would go
out there on the tables and they would
bring in puppies and dogs and you would
enter
with them while you were having
cocktails in the afternoon why don't we
do a movie called the Appy hour about
two [ __ ] dudes one guy gets fired
from the radio and one guy makes a movie
about a walrus yeah they both need work
it's like daddy daycare but instead it's
with dogs and it's yappy hour because we
realized we hate at all people and we're
like well you know I like dogs and
they're like that's how we'll [ __ ]
get back on top so we open a bar for
dogs or you know a dog take care [ __ ]
walk-in Center that no it's dog way look
I just like the time we'll figure out
the script later on that's how our yoga
hosers how that's right yeah that's got
to be careful we also like to take a
look at movies and TV shows and find the
mistakes the bloopers the blunders the
gaffes somebody should have caught this
stuff before it reached the audience and
yet they didn't and so we call those
things
[ __ ] that should not be today's [ __ ]
that should not be is from here it's
from London as a matter of fact Lister
not on your life it smells like hummus
this is near Alan sent this and
apparently you know just recently it was
a Batman's 80th anniversary the
character of Batman yes they were
celebrating the 80th anniversary and as
all the breakfast shows as you call them
over here are the morning shows as we do
in the States everybody was doing a
segment on Batman's 80th birthday
rightfully so second to Jesus only he
saved the world right one of the great
characters in all fiction
you can count on him [ __ ] fiction
stuff that [ __ ] just a great guy okay
he's a good live person Kevin he's real
of life is that how you speak about like
he's a good live person yes that's right
I speak about you because there was a
moment there we didn't know which was a
good point yeah yeah I TVs good morning
Britney was celebrating the 80th
anniversary its Piers Morgan of course
favorite he's universally hated here our
home everywhere everybody hates Piers
Morgan Susanna Reid also on that show
we understand you don't like him we got
that also he's not here so right yeah is
he here
so they were celebrating and I love the
picture they used naturally of course
that's my favorite Batman but if you
zoom in you had a 50/50 shot right and
if you didn't know it how does someone
not suss that out before it goes on
television and you don't even have to be
like well Comics verse all you have to
do is be like cheese was how come Batman
wasn't in the Avengers oh yeah oh that's
right he was in the other ones how do
you make that mistake on the dudes 80th
birthday no less cuz he's a fictional
character what I thought it was a real
live guy he is in my heart all right and
also we like to take a look at acting
sometimes bad acting can be so good it
goes all the way around to become
exquisite acting welcome to the world of
exquisite acting with Ralph Garman this
week's exquisite acting comes to us from
Ryan killing is from a film called oak
cha yeah that the big giant lovable
super pig yeah that they're trying to
grow this multinational corporation is
growing these super pigs because first
of all they're delicious and second of
all they leave a low carbon footprint
and they pay for the perfect livestock
for him and the girl and a little girl
who's been a caretaker for this pig she
comes to its rescue and Jake
Gyllenhaal's in the film playing a
character called dr. Johnny Wilcox and
he's a television animal lover kind of a
guest like the Crocodile Hunter was back
in the day in Australia but he's an
American version of that and his choice
how to play this character I don't say
it's over the top
yeah that's exactly what I would say
it's over the top
way way over the top here's this week's
exquisite acting Jake Gyllenhaal as dr.
Johnny Wilcox do you not the face of the
Brando corporation I am you don't even
know if she can do anything but cry
whereas I am loved all over the world
could you sit down and shut the [ __ ]
squeaking and whining I think she speaks
for all of us in this scene he's doing
like Edwin or something that oh my
goodness yes I've loved all over the
world don't you know what is that all
about
not his audition for Mysterio I hope no
I don't think so that would be
embarrassing
we of course joined together every
episode to take a look at all the
entertainment news with a segment called
the HBO headline
[Music]
yeah boy this bond 25 seems to be almost
jinxed this film they've had a hard time
getting it going they've lost a couple
different directors Danny Boyle recently
now Cary Fukunaga is now taking the
reins really but they're shooting in
Jamaica they started shooting finally
production on bond 25 and Daniel Craig
went down on his ankle and polo that was
so hot for a minute oh stop it I was
like who did he blow he went down on his
ankle and really injured his ankle they
had to suspend production of bond 25
they'd had closed it down he went down
on his ankle I believe it's pronounced
uncle no Kevin he twisted his ankle and
it poorly was in a lot of pain they say
from a source on the set Daniel was
reportedly struck down during a
high-speed chase on foot as you'd expect
he was also pretty angry that had
happened he threw his suit jacket on the
ground and sheer frustration hey I hurt
my ankle
Connor you said [ __ ] that let's keep
going I have another ankle I'll just
walk on one leg
Daniel Craig sounded like he was both
shaken and stirred doing a lot of filing
tonight it's fine
I did a lot of filing in high school I
know how to do it they were shooting in
Jamaica they chef production down and
they sent a know Craig to the u.s. to
get x-rays don't they have any hospitals
in Jamaica there they really that's what
this says yeah so when will they well
apparently the the eggs x-ray showed no
serious damage and they're gonna start
shooting again they say within the week
he'll be back to work but I still can't
get over there must be some medical care
in Jamaica right right I mean I think or
is it all herbal medicine there in
Jamaica man it's true that'll heal yeah
but you'd imagine he wants to be
somewhere like say I'm sure he sees it
as a free vacation he's like [ __ ] a
man I getting a bit of be off bond for
like a week but he's shooting at Jamaica
what's been
than that being home I guess yeah before
he injured himself he was shooting with
a new Bond girl named lashana Lynch
there in Jamaica we got a photo of the
two of them working together that's
James Bond taking on his most difficult
mission yet trying to deal with customer
service for his cable company I think I
don't know what he's doing up there but
I'm very excited by the way since I'm
here in the UK I want to take advantage
of my time here they have an exhibit I
won't have anyone seen it at the
National Film Museum they've got Bond in
motion has anyone seen that is it worth
going to yeah I'm gonna check that out
do we have any Ralph report listeners in
the audience by the way anybody
listening there's my guest that the
museum is gonna be you're a UK
correspondent mr. Steve Ashton who is
here tonight by the way Steve where are
you sir
where are you oh come on outside just
wave everybody real quick to all the
garmi members there for the Ralph record
list there's there you go Steve Ashton
everybody that's that's enough that's
enough that's enough thank you thank you
thank you yeah we're gonna go check that
up Halle Berry by the way said she'd be
up to being another James Bond girl if
they would ask again they're not going
to hurl now forget bond she's a wig girl
Wieck lady do we need every reboot
sequel
no we need Jay and Silent Bob reboot
don't get me wrong but they just
announced Josh GAD may star in a Honey I
Shrunk the Kids reboot I mean I'm to be
fair it kind of it's available to be
redone oh well everything is redoing
everything at this point yeah you know
yeah I mean look they've they've done so
many if taken so many of the things
you've loved in change then why wouldn't
that of course that's a concept you
could totally do again I understand you
could do it but Rick Moranis in that
film to me it's just it's just perfect I
thought I was late films just like Jack
Nicholson was the perfect Joker yes then
one day he was replaced by Heath Ledger
and now Heath Ledger looks like he's
about to be replaced sorted by peanut
Joaquin's performances you know at a
certain point like that's a con
that they could keep going John I'm not
like [ __ ] I can't wait and [ __ ] although
I think he's funny I like Josh got a lot
in this film apparently they're gonna
he's gonna play Nick zalinsky who is the
new son grown-up son that's all you had
to do is connect the [ __ ] - oh my god
I can't wait to [ __ ] see this now but
what if Nick Solinsky makes a shrink ray
and then shrinks his kids and then they
go swimming in Cheerios or whatever it's
[ __ ] done man as long as it's like he
was the little boy in the first movie aw
[ __ ] man that's all I want her movie I
just wanted this vicious loop of things
that I've seen until I die I want
sequels to everything I see and then one
day I drop dead that's it that's very
ambitious at least they're doing that at
least it's not like a true like reboot
where though like a man this is the
first time this ever happened it's a
reboot slash sequel it's a really goes
in the Attic and he pulls the tarp off
his father's old shrink gun I'm sure
that's it
stop it I'm being bad that's not good
I'm saying [ __ ] scene right there oh
I'm sampling Eid it's going to be
hackneyed to work [ __ ] Theory that's
what I've here in that you missed your
calling as a screenwriter man you may
[ __ ] her than [ __ ] about it but [ __ ]
that that was a magical scene right
there you put me right in the [ __ ]
movie I'm sorry ya banned the Cheerios
I'll start making hacker remakes here's
a remake I can get behind Bill Murray
has announced he's now willing to do
another Ghostbusters film now that's a
movie I would watch to get Ernie
together and Bill Murray and Dan Aykroyd
and having strap on the proton packs
again aren't they well jason reitman a
son of Ivan who was the original
director of the first two films he is
doing a third Ghostbusters and now it
looks like for the first time ever in
this conversation Bill Murray's on board
to return to his role of Peter Venkman
all that being there would not be fun
yes yeah he was the interview and he
said I have no hartfield because it was
a long time it was believed that he just
wanted to distant distance himself from
those films and he said I never had any
hard feelings about those films that
franchise paid for my son's college he
said we made this thing we are the
caretakers of it is a great thing and it
was really a fun movie to make it's
real movie with some really funny stuff
in it for years they said we can't make
another ghostbusters because Bill Murray
won't change the deal he made with Sony
in 1984 while there right no I never did
and never will so apparently they pony
up enough cash to make him return to the
franchise he always blamed Sony now he
said that's what the that's what always
was holding things up was just paying
him was just money yeah and now he's
getting now apparently he can I though
he might return with Jason Reitman for
the third Ghostbusters oh yeah and I
wanted to give everyone a heads up I
just saw this in the news this is well
it's called an experience with comm if
you ever heard of this business or not
but they are offering some unique
experiences here in the UK coming up
they are have it's it's a special
evening with like Kevin does evening
with Kevin Smith these are superstars
who are now starting to cash in on your
game mister actually they're probably
cashing in on their game same thing like
basically I would go out and talk about
[ __ ] I've done now they're like oh you
can do that right that's what I'm saying
they're taking a page out of your
PlayBook oh they can always do that
though
well they never did until now Sylvester
Stallone just been announced will be
appearing in London and Birmingham doing
a one-man show where he talks about his
life that would be a show I'd like to
sit through would it really just him
yelling at you for two hours
yeah what would that sound like I wonder
so anyway I was like making a movie
right and still is like about a boxer
range named fighting lady championship
what totalk I'm talking be a lot of
addict
Arnold Schwarzenegger will be appearing
in Newport and Birmingham with an
experience with calm so he'll be sitting
there holding yeah so look I used to
lift things that's where heavy and I got
the big and swollen haha that's hot
it'd be like that for two hours but the
most interesting one at Glasgow Leeds in
London and even with Mel Gibson yeah now
that's a party that's a good time do you
have a Mel Gibson impression I don't
because he's so shit-faced you don't
even have to you just have to drink like
him and I plan to do that later on this
evening
how drunk is he gonna get that's gonna
be awesome do you think he'll skip over
parts of the I think he won't bring up
sugar tits or his arrests I don't think
anytime in music news Madonna is slated
to perform at the Eurovision finals on
Saturday and that's the song contest but
that's the big song all over Europe
saying instead so wait who did it last
year who who did it last year
like who was the famous I think if I
believe the Israel won last year because
it's currently being held in Tel Aviv
then that usually no I'm sorry
who was the Madonna of last year I don't
know if they I don't know I don't know
if they always necessarily have big-time
performances on the show was that right
yeah Justin Timberlake he did it one
year occasionally do it but I don't
think it's a tradition but they're
saying that although she's announced
he's gonna do two songs from her
upcoming album madam X the producer said
that may not be the case for the simple
reason we don't have a signed contract
from her yet so they may not use her
unless they sign she signs the contract
she's also gonna do a London Palladium
residency here in the UK and January of
2020 she's gonna start playing at the
Palladium through the 26th through
February 2nd a bunch of shows she says I
am doing a theater tour have you ever
experienced the magic of theater she
asked the intimacy of a theater I want
to have an intimate experience with my
fans so she'll probably blow you I'm
guessing if you go it sounds like and
while she's there she promises to
explain why and she looks like a bad wax
museum version of herself when she shows
up
it's like Madame Tussauds is melting
over there what's going on
more music news this is actually sad
britney Spears's longtime managers
announced that she may never perform
again wait Britney or the manager who's
not performing Britney Spears would be
the performer he would be the manager
yeah she's done well he says that given
her current state and she's undergoing a
psychological evaluation because she's
really
chuckling with her mental health that
she certainly has no interest in
performing now or any time in the
foreseeable future and he said she may
never do it again wow that was that came
out uh I mean I guess it didn't come out
of nowhere but that that was rather
sudden weren't she just in court like
last week or something well she left the
residency in Vegas where she was
performing because her father was ill
and apparently also turns out her her
meds were not working any longer so that
she went into a mental health facility
and now her parents are fighting over
her conservatorship yes and then she
walked out of court barefoot by the way
people are like why are some shoes and
also get her to a doctor and sadly
someone who has not announced that
they're not going to perform anymore
Justin Bieber is in the news this week
I know why I'll tell you why
that's right I felt that one whose
reverberations in the air a paparazzo
photographer is suing Justin Bieber for
serious injuries that he suffered in
July of 2017 when Justin Bieber was
pulling away from church and ran him
over
what would Jesus do where's your Savior
now he would gun it apparently and
that's what he did yeah this
photographer is suing for let me see
permanent disabilities along with
emotional scars he's got a torment torn
meniscus in his knee a screwed up
kneecap and he's now suing for it
doesn't say how much money here but I'm
guessing it's a whole bunch Bieber's
defense by the way it says that he had
the photographer was to blame that he
was in the way of the car and it was his
fault for getting run over I'm gonna
show you the accident okay and you be
the judge this is actual footage of that
photographer you didn't run over I
wouldn't [ __ ] you
[Applause]
holy Sh
[Music]
it sure looks like he turned his he was
speeding away from church yeah who wants
to get away from church that badly he
was in a hurry that was I mean if we
have that did the court have that no
just us it's weird we should do
something no I'm keeping it man no make
it different I don't like justice I told
you that many times I mean that would
seem like an open-and-shut case no I
would think but even at the scene of the
accident we show you another video clip
here's Justin Bieber blaming the
photographer's for being in front of his
truck bar this is amazing
yeah he said you guys are all in front
of the whip man he should go to jail for
calling his truck of a whip that's what
he should do time for [ __ ] death
penalty you guys are all in front of the
whip [ __ ] that guns yeah hope the guy
sues his ass off all right Kevin I are
huge geeks are each week we take a look
at the geek news
[Music]
that's right
Jemaine clementa Flight of the Conchords
Fame one of my favorites has just joined
the cast of the Avatar sequels will be
working with James Cameron to do those
films is he play no I might go now that
Jemaine Clement is in him is he a human
or a blue cat he is a marine biologist
named dr. Ivan Garvin
I'm not Ivan I in Ian Garvin yeah Ivan I
am the Garvin through me he joins a cast
of a Kate Winslet and Oona Chaplin and
Edie Falco and Michelle Yeoh and
Giovanni Ribisi and and of course Sam
Worthington is returning and Sigourney
Weaver and Stephen Lang and the usual
care but he's not playing a blue cat I
to the best of my knowledge I actually
know he could do both right like he
could beat that this doctor guy and then
he is a blue cat when he goes into from
what I remember it's a long time since I
saw that movie it's been a minute none
even a little bit no because there's
about 20 if there's 17 coming yes they
say every it's gonna be Star Wars avatar
Star Wars avatar all the way down we
don't need that do we are you excited
about avatar it's gonna make me love
Star Wars even that's what I'm thinking
congratulations the game of thrones
their most recent episode was the
highest-rated episode in the show's
history thanks understandable right it
was watched by 12.5 million viewers
during its initial broadcast and then
when you garner in when you factor in
rather all the other additional ways you
can watch it online and stuff it made
over 18 million viewers that episode Wow
that is crazy so do the movie math on
that if everyone paid 10 bucks to go see
it like at a movie theater 18 million
times 10 would be a gajillion dollars as
awesome anything happens next week
though it's all over right that's gonna
be the highest rated I'm sure it'll beat
this one and then it'll be all over
HBO said if we had known people like
this much we would have canceled them
years ago a lot of viewers that way and
speaking of Game of Thrones and as it
been announced by the Disney people that
the creators of the game of Thrones TV
series David Benioff been enough rather
and the DB Weiss are going to be the new
steerers of the Star Wars universe is
that the official title years of the
Star Wars universe and I'm doing
whatever I can come on I'm with you I
don't know man I think at the end of the
day like they've proven they could tell
a long-form story over a couple seasons
and I know you can build a race around
here like hey man it's not ending the
exact way I want to but you got to give
it up to them they've kept the ball in
the air this long and stuff I'd trust
him with the Star Wars
we're gonna three they're gonna do first
of the new three entries that will hit
screens on 2022 it's gonna be a while
two suites in another Star Wars film and
so that's because they're concentrating
on the actual the the Disney Plus like
TV show right yeah we'll see man oh yeah
we'll see Star Wars material but we
don't see official Star Wars films till
2022 so but we didn't say no man and I
know this characters near and dear to
your heart Kevin's Swamp Thing is now
joining the DC Universe yeah they just
released a little teaser this week with
Abby arcane and her mossy boyfriend have
you seen this I have no it's very sexy
you're gonna want to [ __ ] a plant after
you watch this I always do anyway
suck a plane you do indeed here's a
little teaser from the upcoming Swamp
Thing on DC Direct strange things have
been out here in the swamp
sometimes the man of your dreams turns
out to be a monster
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
sexy man yeah
man you will believe you can [ __ ] a
plant yes you see that big vine comes
out like this you think that's how they
do it it's gonna be awesome
before we say goodnight boys and girls
we've got one last bit of business we
have to say or the latest and greatest
about one of our favorite actors Liam
Neeson and the size of his enormous
penis be a gross ism Liam Neeson seen
penis that's right you folks are kind
enough every week to send in new facts
about Liam Neeson's [ __ ] here are this
week's Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it
turned Lady gaga
into Lady Gag Gag is so big well big
ball Big Ben was being renovated it took
its place they just stuck some clock
hands on the head I understand Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it can drink
Ralph's under the table well we'll see
about that I'll have you know Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big it often
cosplays as Donald Trump we've got a
picture by the way of love recent
comic-con and if you want to say that
[Applause]
there is there's the president and
lastly Liam Neeson's [ __ ] is so big
to avoid pregnancy he has to pull out
the day before he has sex ladies and
gentlemen of London have you had a good
time this evening my goodness gracious
me thank you so much for being here this
evening cannot thank you enough for
coming out but there is no show without
the guy to my left give it up for mr.
Ralph [ __ ] Garmin ladies gentlemen
let's hear it for my pal and Babel
brother mr. Kevin Smith and that is
Hollywood babble-on for this week I'm
Kevin Smith I'm Ralph Garman babble the
[ __ ] off
[Music]